I hate hugging I love hugging I felt
like that was coming
sometimes I love hugs more than
breathing if it was up to me I'd greet
everyone with a hug unless it's somebody
I know really well it's always made me
like really uncomfortable I love hugging
I hate hug I do I like how to make eye
contact with Jameson as I hug no what do
people do that
I don't know oh come on and just take it
all in yeah and taking it in oh we got
yours touching we just stand here like
this just let it happen
don't hyper aware of all of the parts of
our bodies that are touching our boobs
are not good it's like whimpering it's
okay Kevin don't do that you're hard to
be very fast yeah because I'm hungry oh
my gosh she's got the backpack it's just
so bad
there we go was he on this falls
backwards
and I feel like we're more friends than
we'd have been if we stood here for 20
seconds not like yeah just like hanging
out you don't normally hug people for
more than like maybe even three seconds
so the fact that we did it 20 seconds
kind of like created that sense of we're
there for each other I think people
should hug more I feel like the world
would be a much better place
you